♪ I've been living with
drama, I'm on my knees ♪
♪ Can you pray for me, Mama ♪
- I've been kicking people
off the Apollo stage,
for what, 31 years?
If you're not good enough,
you get booed off the stage.
(laughs)
The audience love it.
♪ So good, so good, not so good ♪
I'm C.P. Lacey, the executioner
at the world famous Apollo Theater.
All together now, “Boo!”
(laughing)
Welcome to the Apollo
Amateur Night, are you ready?
Amateur Night at the Apollo
is the granddaddy to all
of these shows that you look at today:
“X-Factor,” “America's Got
Talent,” “American Idol.”
You come and you sing or you
dance or you do your magic
or tell a joke or poem, and
the audience will decide
whether you go on to the next level
or whether you get booed off of the stage.
That's where I come in, grrrr!
(upbeat music)
My role is to educate
you about your own talent
or lack thereof.
Our booing policy is this:
There is a boo here, a boo
there, a boo here, then the boos
just get paramount.
We have a noise meter back stage,
and when it reaches a certain boo level,
the next thing you know there is a siren,
enter the executioner to kick you off
of my stage.
(audience applauding)
The executioner character
changes after every execution.
At the top of the show,
I'll gong someone off
as Michael Jackson
♪ You've been hit by,
you've been struck by ♪
♪ A boo criminal ♪
- The Godfather of Soul, James Brown
♪ So true, so true, you just got a boo ♪
♪ Da da da da, hey, hit me ♪
Prince.
♪ Di di di did boo ♪
The Apollo Theater is a place
where we, as African Americans
could go and perform.
Folks like Ella Fitzgerald,
Sammy Davis, Jr., James Brown,
and Lauren Hill have
graced the Apollo stage.
I don't enjoy kicking people
off the stage, per se.
If time allows, I try to get
to the person who got booed off
the stage, and just encourage
them and console them.
Go back to the woodshed, learn
your craft, and come back.
And when you're very, very
good, we'll give you the claps.
The Apollo always invites you
to come back and try again.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Thank you, man, thank you Apollo!
- Every week, without fail, when they say,
"Here is the executioner
saying goodnight to you folks,
thanks for coming in,"
there's always someone that
goes, "Boo, I hate you!"
(laughs)
They just love being a part
of the Apollo audience.
(audience applauding)